Blick in die Zukunft der Arbeit sie
sagen das ist eine Revolution die uns ja
jetzt gerade ins Haus steht die ist
mindestens so groß wie die industrielle
Revolution und die hatte er den
unglaublichen Einfluss auf das Leben
aller die die damals gelebt haben bis
heute auf uns nicht zuletzt auch was das
Klima angeht und sie sagen das wird eine
Revolution die wird erstens gigantisch
und zweitens die kommt in den nächsten
fünf Jahren und sie wird nicht mehr den
klassischen Arbeiter so sehr treffen
sondern sie wird die Leute mit wir haben
das gesagt Kostüm und Anzug treffen die
Leute mit einer klaren Karriereplanung
die Leute in den Büros
das macht sich fest an einem kleinen
englischen Adjektiv was häufig im
Bereich künstliche Intelligenz fällt
generativ
das bedeutet wir haben zum ersten Mal
auch öffentlich zugänglich sogar mit
sowas wie chachybt eine schöpferische
tätige künstliche Intelligenz das heißt
konkret ich sage einer künstlichen
Intelligenz schreibt einen Text mit
diesen Eigenschaften und sie tut es und
das auf einem Niveau was derzeit
menschenähnlich vielleicht sogar in
manchen Bereichen Menschen besser ist
und dadurch werden ganz viele Leute die
in den Büros sitzen und die heute noch
bis übermorgen Nachmittag eine dead
haben dass sie einen Text schreiben wo
ihnen die Chefin gesagt hat sie soll mal
ABC zusammenfassen und das wird
innerhalb von wenigen Sekunden
stattfinden können und ob das
juristische Texte sind oder gebraucht
Texte ob das Einschätzung
Zusammenfassung Quartalszahlen
irgendwelche Präsentationen sind das
geht wirklich in Sekunden und zwar in
einer Qualität wo ich sagen würde ob da
jetzt jeden Person die in so einem Büro
sitzt dran kommt weiß ich nicht
und dann kommt dazu dass ich das auch
noch ständig verbessert das heißt ganz
konkret wir haben heute schon die
Situation dass ein Abteilung x 15 Leute
die schreiben sagen wir mal
Gebrauchstexte für die Website von
Konzern wir haben ständig zu tun was ich
die Produkte weiterentwickeln eben noch
sind es 15 und heute schon mit den
Mitteln von heute müssen es nur noch
drei sein drei nur noch 3 genau wie
lange ist es her dass wir hier uns über
Chat GPT unter künstliche Intelligenz
das war im März diesen Jahreszeiten
genau und jetzt schon ist die
Entwicklung so viel weiter man kann seit
März woran machen Sie das fest vor allem
an der Veröffentlichung von der neuen
Generation von künstlichen Intelligenz
die Technologie dahinter heißt GPT
passenderweise als sonst das letzte mal
unterhalten haben war das GPT free also
Nummer drei jetzt ist es Nummer 4 was
was kann das mehr Nummer 4 kann mehr
dass es unter anderem Deutsch sehr viel
besser be das ist zum Beispiel einen
neuen Generation wirklich nebenbei und
aus Versehen über 120 Sprachen gelernt
hat ohne dass die Programmierer das so
beabsichtigt hätten einfach durch
Analyse von Sprachen im Netz
die Wissen teilweise noch nicht mal
welche Sprachen Chat GPT inzwischen
beherrscht das heißt auch sowas wie
Übersetzung findet inzwischen in einem
Niveau statt für die allermeisten
Aufgaben im Alltag völlig ausreichend
sind
wir wissen inzwischen dass Chat GPT
Programmierung in einer Weise beherrscht
das simplere Programmierarbeiten ganz
simpel ausgelagert werden können es gibt
andere Anbieter die reduzieren die Zeit
die ein Programmierer eine
Programmiererin braucht um einen Code zu
schreiben auf ein Zehntel das heißt du
brauchst auch die vermeintlich top
sichereren zukunftsberufe Programmierer
die sind davon gefahren die sind vor
allem deswegen nicht in Gefahr weil sehr
viel mehr Menschen gesucht werden aber
und das muss man so sagen einer
Abteilung aus Entwicklern wie man es im
Software Kontext nennt eine Abteilung
EntwicklerInnen und Entwicklern die kann
schon heute ziemlich stark reduziert
werden und diese wir haben letztes Mal
im März haben wir darüber gesprochen
über die Möglichkeit sozusagen also
Fakes deep Fakes stimmenimitation all
diese Dinge es hängt damit Sprache
zusammen absolut das heißt da gibt es
jetzt zur nächsten Sprung definitiv ja
ich habe den auch mitgebracht wenn Sie
das vielleicht wissen wollen wir haben
uns ja beim letzten Mal über die
theoretische Möglichkeit unterhalten
damals war das noch relativ schwierig
vor allem weil die künstlichen
Intelligenzen sind ja sehr sehr viele
unterschiedliche sehr stark auf die
englische Sprache geeicht waren
inzwischen gibt es das auch ein bisschen
plastischer im deutschen ähm ich habe
das mal vorbereitet das ist tatsächlich
nur
wenige Minuten die das als Vorbereitung
braucht ich habe von jemanden den sie
wahrscheinlich kennen die Stimme
vorbereitet als Klone nämlich Olaf
Scholz und wir können jetzt mal
gemeinsam beschließen was Olaf Scholz
sagen soll
ja ähm ja wir hatten ja soweit ich weiß
vor kurzem Markus Söder hier im Studium
ja und da würde ich einfach mal sagen
ich lasse jetzt Olaf Scholz etwas sagen
mit einer geklonten Stimme
mein Name ist Olaf Scholz ich bin
Bundeskanzler der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland ich freue mich sehr dass
Markus Söder hier im Studio von Markus
Lanz
zugegeben hat dass er nicht
Kanzlerkandidat der Union wird denn ein
Mann den ich schon einmal Lappen genannt
habe Friedrich Merz ist für mich viel
leichter zu schlagen
der Sendung war ein schöner Moment ein
sehr lustiger Moment von unserer sich
gut ja jetzt mal ich bin ja nicht so ein
Lappen der 12 Jahre davon läuft oder
nicht mal von einer Frau geschlagen
worden bin das war der Satz ich bin
Bundeskanzler der Bundesrepublik
Deutschland ich freue mich sehr dass
Markus Söder hier im Studio von Markus
Lanz zugegeben hat dass er nicht
Kanzlerkandidat der Union wird denn ein
Mann den ich schon einmal Lappen genannt
habe Friedrich Merz ist für mich viel
leichter zu schlagen
wow das ist jetzt so spontan entstanden
man muss sich immer vergegenwärtigen
dass die Qualität zunimmt das ist
unterhaltsam und lustig und auch gar
nicht ernst gemeint absolut und das hat
Olaf Scholz auch nie gesagt dass er
würde selber vermutlich darüber lachen
wenn das wird aber das kann man
natürlich auch anders sein einsetzen ne
das kann man noch anders einsetzen was
ich natürlich auch getan habe ich
erlaube mir das jetzt immer
BürgerInnen und Mitbürger mein Name ist
Olaf Scholz ich bin Bundeskanzler der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland hiermit gebe
ich bekannt dass ich morgen das
Parlament auflösen werde anschließend
werde ich die Exekutivgewalt der
Bundesregierung an Präsident Putin
übergeben vielen Dank für Ihre
Aufmerksamkeit und viel Glück das ist
schlimm wird nie passieren natürlich das
ist ein Fake das ist künstlich
hergestellt
das andere war viel lustiger aber
gefahren
die Dimension wir waren die Wirkmacht
wir kriegen ein Gefühl dafür was auf uns
zukommen zum Beispiel in Wahlkämpfen und
plötzlich merkt man da schon eine andere
Epoche angefangen und das geht nicht nur
für solche Fakes das geht natürlich auch
für diese wird macht die sich in der
Arbeit umsetzen
Thema sozusagen
was bedeutet das für die Arbeitswelt
das bedeutet dass Dinge die früher nur
von Menschen gemacht werden können
konnten heute schon von Maschinen
erledigt werden können und damit
skalierbar werden das bedeutet ganz
viele Arbeiten die bis eben noch als
absolut sicher gehalten sind nicht mehr
so sicher und wir reden hier nicht davon
dass sie abgeschafft werden wir reden
hier davon dass die Arbeit sich
verschiebt und das ein Muster wirksam
wird das von 100 Menschen meiner
Einschätzung nach zehn weiterhin in Lohn
und Brot stehen werden hoch bezahlt
werden dass ein Anteil x sagen wir mal
30 40 Prozent dieser 100 Menschen dass
die mehr oder weniger unverändert vor
sich hinarbeiten unter Einsatz von
ki-instrumenten das aber gut 30%, die
die übrig bleiben hängt auch von der
Branche ab dass die dramatisch
verschoben werden und in den meisten
Fällen in Berufe wo sie deutlich
schlechter bezahlt werden wo sie
wahrscheinlich überqualifiziert sein
werden so dass sehr spät erst klar wird
KI wird diese Schere weiter aufmachen
das heißt im Grunde dieses englische
Thema
Dienstleistungsgesellschaft absolut wo
man das auch hat das auch empirisch
belegt bei 20 30 Prozent der Leute
arbeitet den Berufen für die sie
eigentlich überqualifiziert werden am
Ende sind sie Paketfahrer ne ich nichts
gegen Paketfahrer aber es gibt natürlich
Menschen für die und das wird das große
Problem in der kommenden
Arbeitsgesellschaft mit KI sein die
überqualifiziert sein für ihren Job
überqualifizieren sein werden für einen
Job und zwar natürlich auch was sich in
der Bezahlung wieder schlägt über
qualifiziert und unterbezahlt das wird
eines der großen Probleme in einer
ki-arbeitsgesellschaft werden wenn ich
ganz kurz
teilen die Analyse von Sascha Logo und
sind sehr eigentlich glaube ich dass wir
eine hochdynamische Entwicklung haben
wir rechnen damit wir haben Denkfabrik
digitale Arbeitsgesellschaft
Bundesarbeitsministerium die übrigens KI
einsetzen mit einem Tool über 250
Millionen Informationen um Trends
voraussehen zu können die sich in der
Arbeitswelt durch Digitalisierung vor
allem durch Kia arbeiten und wir haben
relativ keine Gewissheiten aber
plausible Annahmen die sich
Arbeitsmärkte entwickeln sie setzen
künstliche Intelligenz wir haben eigenes
Tool wir haben ein deutsches KI
Observatorium dass die Auswirkungen auf
Arbeit und Arbeitswelt untersucht das
scannt alle möglichen wissenschaftlichen
Publikationen Nachrichten die es dazu
sagen wie die Zukunft der deutschen
Arbeitszeit
aber plausible Annahme ich mache mal
drei Beispiele ganz schnell das erste
ist wir haben Bereiche in der Industrie
wo die Arbeit nicht verschwindet
wo KI er hilft auch wettbewerbsfähig zu
sein also der deutsche Maschinenbauer
heiratet die KI
ich war gerade auf der Hannover Messe ja
und wir müssen dafür sorgen dass die
Potenziale die es für Produktivität gibt
für neue Geschäftsmodelle gerade in
unseren Stärken industrielle Produktion
Mittelstand auch gehoben wird das
Riesenaufgabe zweiter Bereich aber immer
konkret was heißt das übersetzt dass das
verschiedene Tätigkeiten tatsächlich
nicht von Menschen gemacht werden
sondern Produktivität gehoben wird und
Menschen sich auf andere Tätigkeiten im
Betrieb konzentrieren werden
also beispielsweise können Sie ganze
Prozesse
automatisieren mit KI das geht bisschen
aber eben zu den verwaltungsjobs wenn es
zum Beispiel um Personal Recruiting
kommt ich komme gleich drauf zweiter
Gedanke wir werden erleben weil
handelbank und Versicherungen zuerst
dass das passiert geschrieben hat das
nämlich gut qualifizierte Arbeit auch
ersetzt ist da geht es dann nicht mehr
um Weiterbildung von Beschäftigten
sondern berufliche Neuorientierung und
es gibt einen Bereich der wird ein Boom
an Arbeitskraft Nachfrage geben soziale
Dienstleistungsberufe Gesundheit Bildung
Pflege wo K i existiert und entlasten
kann Nummer drei Beispiele zu nehmen
Fachkräftemangel gesprochen es wird uns
auch helfen ein Stück der Lücke zu
schließen wenn es richtig gut angehen
aber wir müssen auch ganz offen darüber
reden die Arbeit wird uns nicht ausgehen
aber sie wird für viele Menschen anders
sein und wir werden damit helfen müssen
dass die Menschen von heute auch die
Arbeit von morgen machen können dass das
Thema Qualifizierung Weiterbildung und
es ist auch die Frage wie
Arbeitsorganisation ist und da gibt es
stärken und riesige Chancen die
Arbeitswelt menschlicher zu machen und
auch ein paar Entwicklung die finde ich
richtig
bewusstärken und riesige Chancen sagen
ich hätte sagen Stärken und Schwächen
wer meine ja ich will mal zwei Beispiele
aus dem Leben sagen gerade Dinge Angst
machen ja also ich habe wir haben auch
mit dem KI Observatorium gucken uns
betriebliche Wirklichkeit an wo das
schon eingesetzt ist und gutes Beispiel
ist im Nahverkehr ich glaube in
Süddeutschland wird Kai eingesetzt in
der Mischung von Streckenplänen und
Personal Einsatz das ist ein gutes
Beispiel weil es macht die Entscheidung
sicherer es macht den Verkehr sicherer
und den Stress leute das ist richtig gut
jetzt habe ich einen schwächeres
Beispiel
bei dem es die Ambivalenz einfach mal zu
zeigen das sind dann eins aus der
Personalwirtschaft vital Daten von
Beschäftigten kann man heute wunderbar
ermitteln man kann sie natürlich im
Arbeitseinsatz einsetzen das kann zur
Ausbeutung und Überwachung führen und
dagegen muss eine Gesellschaft auch
vorgehen wie taldaten heißt
Gesundheitsdaten am Arbeitsprozess
Herzfrequenz alles mögliche das können
sie stressblut hoch
Blutzuckerspiegel was auch immer da gibt
es bestimmte Sachen da finde ich darf
der Arbeitgeber das nicht wissen
ist passiert wir haben heute schon die
Möglichkeit zum Beispiel mit einer
stimmfrequenzanalyse eine Vielzahl von
Krankheiten zu bestimmen psychische z.B
psychische Störung klinische
Depressionen posttraumatische
Belastungsstörungen bestimmte
Herzkrankheiten Partner sondern sogar in
Augsburg ist die Forschung sehr weit
vorne dass ich mit Hilfe einer
Stimmanalyse auch Corona diagnostizieren
kann
und jetzt stelle ich mir das Ersatz wir
können anhand der stimmt der Modulation
können Sie sagen der hat wahrscheinlich
einen es fantastisch damit
diagnostizierbar Depression auch
Depressionen auch eine Vielzahl von
Herzkrankheiten und das heißt dass ich
das geht sogar übers Telefon an einer
stimmfrequenzanalyse feststellen könnte
ob die Person die gerade in dieses
Telefon spricht bestimmte Krankheiten
hat da muss man jetzt nicht besonders
gewieft sein oder prognostisch veranlagt
um sich vorzustellen was dafür
Möglichkeiten dahinter sind und
natürlich sind die strukturell verboten
ja entweder implizit oder explizit aber
dass die Möglichkeit da ist das ist
natürlich jetzt nicht besonders
Beispiel bei der Personal noch ganz kurz
sagen weil das die ambivalenzzeit sie
können mit KI heute im Recruiting also
im Personal anwerben echt tolle
Möglichkeiten schaffen um wirklich die
Besten zu bekommen die wir für einen Job
brauchen wenn
die Daten richtig sind also das ist
super ich mach mal ein Beispiel aus dem
Bereich der Bundesregierung uns auch
noch mal wie Sascha Logo an einem
Beispiel theoretisch zu machen wenn wir
zum Beispiel mein Staatssekretär oder
eine Staatssekretärin suchen und wir
würden alle Daten nehmen aller
Staatssekretäre seit 1949 und die
einspeisen und zur Grundlage machen dann
kommt Mist raus warum sind vor allem
Männer ja es gibt mehr Staatssekretärin
seit 1949 die Hans hießen als
frauenbremse kriegen sie also ja ich
würde sagen das kann zur falsche führen
gut gemacht und transparent ist das
antidiskriminierend schlecht gemacht
kriegen sie die schlechtesten und
diskriminieren Leute und darum geht's
die Transparenz zu schaffen und dafür zu
sorgen dass der Rahmen so ist dass wir
die guten Dinge nutzen dass die KI den
Menschen dient und nicht umgekehrt also
ich möchte jetzt gerne mal kurz einhaken
weil ähm
Herr heiter besprochen und ich finde das
zeigt eigentlich ganz gut in welcher
Lage wir uns befinden in diesem Land wir
observieren nicht observieren und wir
agieren nicht ja wir sprechen hier
gerade über Technologien die alle nicht
in Deutschland entstanden sind ja wir
haben ein erhebliches Defizit was
Digitalisierung angeht ja Deutschland
hat sich eigentlich mal vorgenommen
Weltmarktführer zu werden im Bereich
künstlicher Intelligenz ja inzwischen
müssen wir aufpassen dass wir nicht zur
Lachnummer werden weil unser Abstand
einfach so groß geworden ist ja wir
leben immer noch in einer Fax Republik
dieses dieser Wunsch weltmarktführerin
zu werden ja der ist einfach nahezu kaum
noch Reifen sehr gut also weil man dafür
Daten braucht und das ist der Punkt
sondern man braucht auch das Geld dafür
man braucht die Fachkräfte dafür und man
braucht natürlich die Rechenkapazitäten
dafür und in all diesen Dingen steht
Deutschland einfach sehr schlecht da und
das ist natürlich fatal wenn wir man
diesen Zukunftstechnologien teilhaben
wollen wenn wir nicht nur über die
riesigen sprechen wollen sondern auch
diese Chancen nutzen möchten ich möchte
dass der Grundschule ganz kurz warum
biontech jetzt zum Beispiel genau 19
Teil der Forschung weil die Daten
brauchen genau das sind bemerkenswertes
Beispiel dafür Jack hat sich jetzt
entschieden ist ja wirklich eines der
leuchtturmunternehmen hier in
Deutschland nach London zu geben und
gehen und dort die Krebsforschung
hochzuziehen
Geberland gemacht im länderfinanziert
lassen ja es gab was machen die da in
London genau die haben einen Unternehmen
aufgekauft was mit künstliche
Intelligenz versucht völlig neue Ansätze
in der Medizin insgesamt zu finden ganz
spezifisch hat er bei Songtext sehr
lange auch mit Hilfe von künstlicher
Intelligenz geforscht an Krebsmitteln
der sind ja nur zwischendurch weil sie
bestimmte Technologien sehr gut
beherrschen umgeschwenkt auf den
Impfstoff aber grundsätzlich zeigt dass
die Problematik wir sind in Deutschland
sehr groß mit Worten und sehr kleinem
Handeln ich erinnere hier an einen
ehemaligen
spd-vizekanzler der gesagt hat ich
glaube es war 2016 oder 2017 bis 2025
werden wir die weltbeste digitale
Gigabit Infrastruktur haben das ist
bitte wer war das ich glaube der kam aus
Niedersachsen genau kann ich es aber
nicht mehr sagen
[Musik]
Gabriel sehr vollmundig wir sind 2023
Mitte 2012 23 anderthalb Jahre von 25
entfernt und wir haben immer noch eine
App bärmliche digitale Infrastruktur in
jedem durchschnittlichen Regionalexpress
habe ich gar keinen Empfang damit ich
gar nicht erst von irgendwelchen LTE
Evolution Geschichten anfangen oder gar
von 5g die Problematik die sich uns
stellt wir kündigen viel an und dann
kommt sehr wenig oder nicht und das was
kommt ist sollte man erstmal Regulierung
da kommen irgendwelche Leute aus dem
Busch gesprungen und sagen wir brauchen
die schärfsten Regeln der Welt wir haben
diese Eigenschaften dann auch noch auf
die EU übertragen die EU kommt jetzt und
sagt wir wollen die ersten sein die
künstliche Intelligenz richtig
hammerhart und umfassend regulieren ich
zitiere fast es wirklich fast ganz
genauso gesagt worden ohne hammer hart
ja aber tatsächlich umfassen und die
ersten sein die das regulieren wollen
und wir vergessen das ganz viel von dem
was gerade entsteht eben nicht
ausregulierung heraus entsteht sondern
aus einem unternehmerischen Geist ja
häufig erst dann wirksam wird wenn man
die Regulierung ein bisschen klüger was
ja interessant ist ich glaube Sie haben
es irgendwo mal geschrieben und die
Frage würde jetzt aber vor allem das
gehen
wie waren ja immer gut sozusagen in
Evolution also noch mal die drei Prozent
aus dem Verbrenner rauszuholen also
diese diese deutsche Ingenieur genau
gibt ein Fachbegriff dafür
inkrementeller von Gesundheit
und das ist das worüber wir reden ist
disruption ist sozusagen alte
Technologie ein Motten kaputt machen
schreddern um es dann ganz neu
aufzubauen ist das was die Amerikaner so
unglaublich gut beherrschen warum können
wir das nicht ja das ist natürlich die
große Frage und ich weiß auch gar nicht
ob wir es nicht können wir müssen das
nur einfach tatsächlich nur angehen es
sind tatsächlich erst 11% der
Unternehmen die in Deutschland KI
einsetzen ja das ist ja ein dramatischer
Rückstand und wenn wir an diesen Zukunft
merken Teil haben wollen dann müssen wir
jetzt einfach mal
Scholz bist einfach nicht weiter leisten
uns in die Hängematte zu legen und uns
auf diesen Fortschritt den wir einmal
erreicht haben auszuruhen ja wir sehen
ja gerade wie schnell die Entwicklung
geht ja von chachypity 3 auf chaturbt 4
wir müssen wirklich jetzt nicht mehr
ausservieren
wir haben keine Daten bzw wenig Daten
und die die wir haben da muss man erst
17 verschiedene Leute fragen ob es
wirklich sinnvoll ist sie so zu
verwenden oder man die nicht mehr
dreimal noch anonymisieren muss bevor
man sie dann wegschmeißt weil der
Datenschutzbeauftragte dagegen ist es
ist tatsächlich so dass wir hier eine
Bürokratie entwickelt haben die durch
Regulierung und Bremsung auffällt das
ist übrigens nicht nur Datenschutz ich
kriege jedes Mal wenn ich dazu schreibe
irgendwie frontal in die Schnauze von
den verschiedenen
Datenschutzbeauftragten der der Länder
und der Bundesdatenschutzbeauftragten
mach hier aber trotzdem gerne weil ich
sehe dass wir in einem regulierungsland
Leben ja und das geht nicht nur für
Datenschutz sondern auch zum Beispiel um
das Herrn leichter zu machen
viele Leute nicht aber es ist faktisch
verboten im Homeoffice ein Laptop zu
benutzen mehr als nur kurzfristig ja das
ist einfach auf der Ebene
ja das ist hoch gefährlich denn wenn
das stimmt nicht
nur kurzfristig muss man nämlich den die
Tastatur und den Screen voneinander
trennen weil man sonst Hals und
Rückenschmerzen bekommen kann das ist
wirklich das ist im Moment das das
Gesetz das mehr als nur kurzfristig darf
ein Homeoffice
stimmt es dass die Bundesregierung von
Whatsapp ausgeschlossen wurde bei der
datenschutzbeauftrag gesagt er könnte
nicht machen so riskant für euch nee das
ist zieht sich meiner Kenntnis ja also
ich glaube nicht dass Whatsapp auf den
Diensthandys benutzt werden kann genauso
wenig benutzt werden kann
soweit ich das weiß der Bundesregierung
gesagt sie möge doch gefällig Facebook
nicht verwenden das Facebook
von gestern
und da kann man jetzt ganz viel darüber
argumentieren aber das was wirklich klar
es ist wir haben eine Regulierungswut in
diesem Land und leider steht der nicht
eine unternehmerische Schaffung
ich meine Datenschutz ist ja prinzipiell
eine gute Sache ich finde das jetzt
nicht nur schlecht und das Gegenteil
davon ist das was China gerade macht und
ist auch beängstigend zu sehen dass also
ich google ist ja in China als Dienst ja
gar nicht zugelassen hat er dann bei du
und andere aber die sind trotzdem dort
um Forschung zu machen klar weil sie
sich angucken was die Chinesen machen
und weil sie auf diesen um vorstellbaren
Datenschatz auch quasi zugreifen wollen
das ist sehr interessant und setzen
ihrerseits die amerikanische Politik
unter Druck und sagen Freunde müsste
noch ein bisschen lässiger werden mit
Daten weil wir brauchen Daten ansonsten
funktioniert dieses Geschäft der Zukunft
nicht und unser Weg ist der krasse
andere aber was dabei doch entsteht
ironischerweise ist eine neue komplette
Abhängigkeit
die wir nicht mehr im Griff haben also
wir machen uns komplett abhängig von
amerikanischen oder auch chinesischen
tiktok ist zum Beispiel
Konzernen Plattformen die dann dieses
Geschäft betreiben und den vertrauen wir
dann oder müssen wir mehr Vertrauen als
unseren eigenen
Protest das muss geändert werden ich
versuch's mal aus einer Tradition
beschreiben nicht zu verteidigen wo wir
herkommen es gab in den 80er Jahren mal
ein Vorteil des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts
informationelle selbst gegen die
Volkszählung
und damals gab es das alles so nicht
über was für heute reden und die Idee
war damals die der Datensparsamkeit
muss man kein Experte sein zu wissen
dass Big Data und und Datensparsamkeit
ein gewisses Spannungsfeld haben so und
jetzt die Frage wie kommen wir aus der
Falle raus und deshalb
einsetzen erhalten von wem kommt die wer
macht wird tatsächlich selbst
programmiert selber ja meine Leute
können das inzwischen aber ich will ganz
kurz sagen funktioniert das funktioniert
offensichtlich also ich will sagen worum
es jetzt Telefonnummer alles natürlich
also
manchmal überrascht es ja auch es gibt
also es gibt disruptionen die sind ganz
falsch gewesen in Großbritannien hat man
sich aus politischen Gründen ganz von
industrieller Produktionen 80er Jahren
verabschiedet wir Gott sei Dank nicht
jetzt geht es um die Transformation wie
man zum Beispiel industrielle Produktion
und KI verbinden kann wieder
Maschinenbau das hinbekommt das braucht
übrigens Vertrauen warum gehen da viele
nicht in der kritische Masse von Daten
obwohl sie das in der Wirtschaft dauernd
haben Kundenbeziehung
Produktionsprozessen weil sie Angst
haben dass der Konkurrent reinkommen
kann deshalb geht es um KI in der
Wirtschaft wenn man vertrauen kann der
europäische Ansatz über die
Ausgestaltung muss diskutiert werden
aber ist ja nicht alles zu Tode zurück
regulieren mein Grundsatz ist Chancen
und Risiko basiert zu regulieren es gibt
Bereiche gar nicht regulieren also meine
Spotify Liste gehört nicht reguliert das
ist überhaupt nicht schlimm wenn es um
ganz heftige ja ja
aber es gibt Bereiche da geht es
tatsächlich um hochempfindliche Dinge
wir haben vorhin über
meinungsmanipulationen gesprochen die
haben Bereiche da geht es um
sicherheitsverteidigung Einsetzung an
von Waffen natürlich brauchst dafür
Regeln und je mehr uns das in Europa
gelingt in einem größeren
Wirtschaftsraum desto mehr ist es
Vertrauen auch da trotzdem ich Leute
überhaupt nichts was an Defiziten hier
beschrieben wurden aber die Aufgabe muss
doch sein die Dinge nicht nur zu
bejammern und zu beschreiben und zu
sagen oh gott hat er früher schon mal
nicht geklappt sondern Geist zu haben
der das anpackt und ich erlebe habe das
jedenfalls auf der Hannover Messe erlebt
da gab es zwei Riesen Themen wie
inzwischen alle drauf waren das eine ist
Frage Energieversorgung Wasserstoff und
Einsatz in diesem Bereich und das andere
ist die Frage KI oder wie es im
Maschinenbau heißt inzwischen ich glaube
meine Factoring x also es ist nicht mehr
Industrie 4.0 sondern es geht
tatsächlich um die Frage wie man das als
Geschäftsmodell hochskaliert machen kann
und da haben wir durchaus auch bei allen
Defiziten die beschrieben wurden ein
paar Stärken also wenn wir es schaffen
KI wie gesagt und deutsches
Ingenieurswesen nicht gegeneinander zu
denken dann ist das unschlagbar wir
haben gigantische Daten eins will ich
nochmal für den Staat sagen das ist
jedenfalls mein Ziel in der
Sozialverwaltung dass wir KI auch so
einsetzen dass Bürger nicht mehr rennen
müssen sondern dass wir automatisiert
Dinge nach vorne bringen und daran
arbeiten wir mit großer Macht weil ich
bin mit dieser Bürokratie nicht
einverstanden sie ist tatsächlich ein
wachstumshemmnis in jeder Hinsicht und
es macht die Leute kirre sind ja oft
nicht politisch Entscheidungen die Leute
politikverdrossen machen sondern
Alltagserleben und stellt ist stellen
sich einmal vor wir klären im
Sozialstaat zwischen den Behörden wer
welches Recht hat und wer nicht wir
können gegen soziale Missbrauch übrigens
mit KI auch wunderbar von gehen und
dafür finde ich lohnt es sich auch zu
sein
wirklich sehr heftig ein wenn ich bin
überhaupt nicht dagegen dass KI
natürlich auch zu Optimierung von
staatlichen Dienstleistungen eingesetzt
werden zum Wohle der Bürgerinnen und
Bürger und aller Menschen die hier leben
Komma aber ich habe vor einem Jahr in
ein Kind bekommen mit meiner Frau und
das Kind ganz großartige Geschichte aus
beruflichen Gründen musste ich verreisen
weshalb ich für das Kind einen Reisepass
versucht habe zu beantragen mit Betonung
auch versucht nur drei Monate nach der
Geburt war allerdings die Geburtsurkunde
noch nicht da weshalb wir dahin gegangen
sind und gesagt haben zu wir brauchen
jetzt auch wirklich ein Reisepass und
dann sagt die Dame Bürgeramt ja aber das
brauchen sie eine Geburtsurkunde und da
dachte ich ja witzig ich bin ja
hergekommen weil sie diejenigen sind die
die Geburtsurkunde auch ausstellen und
dann hat sie gesagt dass wir wahnsinnig
leid wir brauchen die Geburtsurkunde und
zwar übrigens in Papier nach vorne dann
können Sie nicht darauf zugreifen es
gibt diese Person hier in meinem Arm ist
ne wir können nicht trotz zugreifen weil
ihr Kind in einem Nachbarbezirk geboren
wäre das ist der faktische stand das
zweite Bürgerämter in zwei Bezirken in
Berlin nicht gegenseitig auf Daten
zugreifen können da würde ich sagen ich
sehe eine Idee eines
verbesserungspotenzials bevor man jetzt
mit KI um sich wird aber
also nee wenn man da stehen bleiben ich
wundere mich ein bisschen weil ich kann
dir auch ich kann ihnen auch solche
Ereignisse aus eurem persönlichen Leben
sagen aber ist es nicht Zeit nicht nur
darüber nachzudenken bei so einem
online-zugangsgesetz das viel zu kurz
gedacht dass man jetzt alles digital
beantragen kann das ist schon nicht mehr
interessant und die spannende Frage ist
ob sie Prozesse digitalisiert bekommen
ja das klingt groß und sie werden jetzt
alle aus irgendeiner Verwaltung Beispiel
nennen können für mich ist das
eigentlich Ansporn dafür zu sorgen zum
Beispiel in der Rentenversicherung in
der Arbeitslosenversicherung KI massiv
voranzutreiben und nicht wieder zu kurz
zu springen und sagen oh Gott jetzt
müssen wir dafür sorgen dass als PDF
irgendwie ein Antrag im Netz gibt das
ist finde ich etwas was zu kurz
gesprungen ist und da sind andere Länder
weiter und ich finde von denen kann man
lernen wir haben in Deutschland durch
die föderale Ordnung daheim-schuhe aber
man muss da tatsächlich Standards setzen
sonst wird man in zehn Jahren noch die
debat in dieser selben Tag so viel los
wahrscheinlich machen
Schlusswort und sie überlegen sehr genau
konstruktiv oder ob sie richtig normalen
gehen ja ich muss leider in die hingehen
weil wenn er halt wenn Herr Heil ihr von
von KI in der Verwaltung träumt ja wir
leben noch in analoge starten ja also
das
Vorgängerregierung an der sie auch
beteiligt waren die sich ja vorgenommen
575 Verwaltungsdienstleistungen zu
digitalisieren und das nein und das ist
nicht gelungen ja aber die
neuerungsgesetz hat das die
Bundesagentur für Arbeit umgesetzt aber
das ist zu wenig
geschafft
demokratisch ist jetzt zwei Leute sagen
das ist falsch sie sind
nicht stimmt
nicht okay
genau
wir haben wirklich diese ich habe gesagt
dieser ganze Ansatz von diesem
Online-Zugang aus meiner Sicht viel zu
kurz aber es gibt ein paar die haben es
hinbekommen und mein Prinzip steht
Bundesagentur für Arbeit gucken sich das
an die haben auch noch nicht alles
perfekt aber die haben die die sind
ziemlich warm und jetzt geht um die
anderen 526 alles schön Rede es geht
einfach nur darum dass wir in diesem
Land uns mal angewöhnen sollten dass wir
nicht immer nur bejammern und von den
schlechten Beispiel reden sondern von
den guten Beispiel wo es geklappt
wir haben uns die Dinge so lange schon
geredet dass wir jetzt wirklich ich bin
ja sehr gut ich habe ja selbst gesagt
mich mir geht diese Bürokratie richtig
auf dem Zeiger so um es nicht anders zu
sagen ja glaube ich allen Menschen in
Deutschland auf den Zeigern diese
Bürokratie aber sie haben sich mit ihrer
Ampelkoalition überhaupt kein neues Ziel
gesetzt bis wann sie jetzt die
Verwaltung digitalisieren wollen ja dass
du gut und nicht einfach viele rausholen
sie doch jetzt schon längst tun
sich Ziele die sich nicht erreichen
jetzt machen sich Leute auf dem Weg und
sagen die Ziele sind nicht groß genug da
müssen sich entscheiden ich bin
Pragmatiker und ich will dass wir Dinge
ändern und sie haben eine Situation das
ist vielleicht ein Unterschied